If you're using Claude code and you think it actually knows your business, it's just pretending to.
Every time you start a new session with Claude, it re reads your files from scratch.
We're looking at hundreds of tokens that are wasted for Claude to just remember what it already knew.
What we're looking at is graphify inside of Obsidian.
Graphify turns your entire code base, your documents, your strategy notes, even your images into this.
A knowledge graph.
It maps how everything in your business actually connects with one another.
And it actually persists.
So you could see how some of my digital assets actually connect to other parts of my code base.
Now, when I ask Claude, how does my content pipeline connect to revenue?
It doesn't grab through 300 files.
It already has the map.
And it was a one time build.
70x fewer tokens per search.
In the next video, I'm going to show you how to set this up, so make sure you shoot me a follow.
And comment AI agent for access to all of my free Claude code guides and templates.